GOOD.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
MAY TWENTY THIRD ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
WE HAVE EIGHTY SIX BILLS
CONSIDER THIS MORNING.
AND WE WILL HAVE MISTER MATHIS
SAID IN FOR MR BOROUGH WELCOME
MR MATHIS.
ALSO KNOW THAT MISTER FUNG HAS
PULLED AB TWENTY NINE NINETY SIX
AND MISTER RODRIGUEZ HAS PULLED
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTEEN SO
NEITHER OF THOSE WILL BE HEARD
TODAY.
NOTICING THE ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WILL GO AHEAD AND BEGIN
AS A SUBCOMMITTEE.
.
MISTER STONE.
MR STONE CAN YOU HOLD FOR ONE
MINUTE LET MISTER BLOOM PRESENT
CA DISCOVERED A BUDGET.
THANK YOU I'M SORRY.
SORRY MR STONE.
MISTER BLOOM TWENTY FIVE TWENTY
EIGHT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
I APPRECIATE THE ACCOMMODATION
AND I WILL BE BRIEF.
THIS IS.
AB TWENTY FIVE TWENTY EIGHT
WHICH SEEKS TO MAKE CALIFORNIA
HABITATS MORE CLIMATE RESILIENT.
IN THE FACE OF ONGOING CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THE STATE'S CURRENT CLIMATE
ADAPTATION STRATEGY IS A
TRIANGLE REPORT.
THE PLANTS PURPOSE IDENTIFIES IS
TO IDENTIFY STATE REGIONAL
CLIMATE CHANGE VULNERABILITIES.
AND POTENTIAL STRATEGIES TO
ADDRESS THESE VULNERABILITIES.
THERE A NUMBER OF CRITICAL ZONES
THAT ARE IMPORTANT FOR
EVERYTHING FROM.
I AM NOT A BREATH.
SPECIES PRESERVATION TO WILDLIFE
PREVENTION.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
MEMBERS SOLELY SEAN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
NO OKAY.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
CHRIS LEAPT FROM THE FINANCE IN
THE FILE.
I THINK YOU.
SAME NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO.
INCLUDE AGAIN I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR ARRIVAL AND WANTING THAT
ABSENCE WE HAVE ONE IN FACT
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD. AND
CALL THE ROLL WHY YOU'RE HERE
MISTER BLOOM THAT WOULD BE GREAT
TO STEPS CLIMB.
AND SECRETARY GONZALEZ FLETCHER.
BIGELOW.
ROOM HERE BONTA.
MATHIS.
CALDERON.
CARILLO.
CHILD CARE EGGMAN.
FONG.
FRIEDMAN. GALLAGHER GARCIA
NAZARIAN. OBERNOLTE QUIRK HERE
BREATH.
SORRY ABOUT THAT MISTER STONE.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS WILL BE
PRESENTING AB TWENTY FORTY NINE.
CHOICE DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
THANK YOU AND AND NO PROBLEM
UNDERSTAND HOW TOUGH IT IS WITH
COMMITTEES THIS IS A BILL WITH
REGARD THIS HERE NEVADA
CONSERVANCY. IT JUST DOES SOME
LIMITED CHANGES THERE'S REALLY
NO COST TO THE STATE'S I ASK FOR
YOUR.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT ACT MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS STUCK
HOUSTON REPRESENTING AND SEE OUR
BUSINESS COUNCIL WE ARE
SPONSORED.
THE BILL HERE TO ANSWER ANY.
THANK YOU.
ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE FILE.
MISTER BIGELOW I THINK HAS A
QUESTION.
THANK YOU MISTER STONE JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION.
RECOGNIZING THAT.
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
RECOGNIZED AS A FOREIGN NATION
AND THIS WILL BE THE STATE'S OUT
FUNDS. BEING UTILIZED FOR.
WOULD WELL THE ULTIMATE
QUESTION IS IS IS A GIFT OF
STATE FUNDS TO A DEFINITION OF A
FOREIGN NATION.
NO IT'S THEY THE EXISTING
STATUTE. TALKS ABOUT TRIBAL
GOVERNMENTS IS RECOGNIZE FEDERAL
IT ALL THIS DOES IS MAKE
ELIGIBLE CALIFORNIA RECOGNIZE
TRIBAL GOVERNMENTS THAT'S THE
ONLY CHANGE.
THANK YOU APPRECIATED.
THANK YOU.
.
WE DO EVER MOTION BY MISS KOREA
A SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU MISTER STONE
LIKE IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL.
MR STATEN AB THIRTY TO FORTY
NINE ENJOY TO DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION LIKE YOU THIS IS
THE ANNUAL BAR DUES. BILL THERE
NO STAY COSTS THERE. THE DUES TO
GO THROUGH THAT ARE BEING PAID
BY THE ATTORNEYS THE ONE THING I
WILL KNOW. FOR. THAT IS OF
INTEREST IS THERE IS AN AUDIT
CLAUSE THAT WE'RE NEGOTIATING
WITH THE STATE BAR RIGHT NOW. WE
EXPECT THEM TO COME BACK FOR A
DUES INCREASE NEXT YEAR AND THE
AUDIT WILL BE THE MECHANISM FOR
US TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND.
THAT.
SCOPE AND THE THE VALUE OF THAT.
DUES INCREASE AND SO THE OUT A
PROVISION IS IS VERY IMPORTANT
THAT'S PROBABLY SOMETHING THAT'S
RELEVANT TO THE
COMMITTEE ASKING ROB.
THANK YOU ARE THERE IN SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT. MORNING MY NAME IS
MICHAEL CON
THANK YOU SIR GOOD MORNING MY
NAME IS MICHAEL COHEN TO KNOW I
AM THE CHAIR OF THE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES OF THE STATE BAR. I AM
SPEAKERS APPOINTEE TO THE BOARD
OF TRUSTEES OF THE STATE BAR. WE
ARE OBVIOUSLY SUPPORTIVE OF OUR
CONTINUED EXISTENCE AND
THEREFORE THE BILL. AND WE
SUPPORT THAT THE REFORM PROCESS
IS UNDERWAY AT THE BAR THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS.
ASSIST US WITH AND I'M HERE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THAT MIGHT
BE.
VERY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
PART OF FINANCE NO FILE.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK SECOND I
MISS CREEL WHICH OCT CLOSE.
RIGHT BACK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL
CALL THANK YOU.
MISTER CHOI IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE
NEXT.
pA BETWEEN NINE THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND THE
MEMBERS.
AB.
TWENTY NINE THIRTY TWO.
DONE RENAME WHEN I COME
BUSINESSES TO CALIFORNIA ACT
PROVISO. IT TAX CREDIT OFFICE
SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE PERCENT THE
FULL BUSINESSES OF THAT MOVED TO
OR EXPAND THAT IN CALIFORNIA.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THE
LEGISLATURE ALL FOR THAT A
SIMILAR SEVENTEEN POINT FIVE
PERCENT.
A TAX CREDIT OF LOW WAGES UP A
TOOL LACKEY.
MARTIN AND.
NORTHROP GRUMMAN TO INCENTIVIZE
THEM OUT TOO LOYALTY THAT THE AT
LARGE.
A MANUFACTURING FACILITY JUST IN
CALIFORNIA.
AB YEAH PONINE NINE THIRTY TWO
WOULD TO SEEK TO EXTEND DISA.
THAT TAX CREDIT UP TO THE UP
BORDER OR. BUSINESS OF
COMMUNITY.
USING THE NUMBERS ARE IN YOUR
ANALYSIS OF STATING THAT THE.
WAGES OF THAT THE QUALIFY FOR
THIS PROGRAM WOULD BE BETWEEN
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT AND A
HUG. THREE HUNDRED FIFTY PERCENT
OF THE MINIMUM WAGE AND THAT
ADDING THE FACT THAT THE MINIMUM
WAGE IS EXPECTED TO.
REACH FIFTEEN DOLLARS ABOUT HOW
WERE. THE AVERAGE ANNUAL. WAGE
JUST FOR ALL QUALIFYING JOB AND
THAT JUST MITCHELL WOULD BE
BETWEEN FORTY SIX THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED. AND THE ONE HUNDRED.
NINE THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED.
THE LOWER END OF THAT THE RANGE
OF FORTY SIX THOUSAND. EIGHT
HUNDRED THE HOUSE WOULD BE IN A
BIG PLACENTA STATE TAX BRACKET.
AND THOSE OF BRINGING ABOUT THE
THIRTY SEVEN HUNDRED DOLLARS. IN
ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUE PUT
EMPLOYEE.
THE HIGHER END OF THAT THE RANGE
OF WOULD BE IN NINE POINT THREE
PERCENT TAX BRACKET AND THUS TO
BRING IN ABOUT THE.
TEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THE IN
ADDITIONAL TAX REVENUE PO
EMPLOYEE.
THOSE SO USEING THE CALCULATIONS
EACH EDITION ON TWENTY EMPLOYEES
TO ADD IT UP WOULD BRING IN
BETWEEN SEVENTY FOUR THOUSAND
EIGHT HUNDRED.
A EIGHTY TWO TWO HUNDRED THREE
THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED THAT IN
ADDITIONAL INCOME TAX OR REVENUE
PUT EACH YEAR.
THIS NUMBER DOES NOT EVEN
INCLUDE THE ADDITIONAL REVENUES
THAT.
NOT THE IS EMPLOYEE IS THAT
WOULD BRING IN A IN SUCH TAXES
HAS A SAYS STACKS UP GAS TAX
ETCETERA.
BY INCREASING THE NUMBER BUT
BUSINESSES ARE OPERATING IN.
THE STATE THE JOBS ARE CREATED.
AND THE REVENUE GENERATED. WOULD
ACT AS A CATALYST.
OF FOR NEW GROWTH IN THE ECONOMY
THOSE TO MITIGATING MUCH WALK
ALL OF THE OUT REVENUE LOSS. OF.
ACCOUNTED FOR IN THE ANALYSIS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK THAT SCHOOL
YOUR AYE VOTE. AT THAN
APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE OF THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD ESTIMATES
REVENUE LOSS OF NINE POINT ONE
MILLION IN EIGHTEEN NINETEEN.
THIRTY ONE MILLION IN NINETEEN
TWENTY AND THIRTY SEVEN MILLION
AND TWENTY TWENTY ONE. AND THEY
ARE STILL EVALUATING MINISTERED
COST.
THANK YOU. SEE NO QUESTIONS
WOULD. WILL TAKE THAT AS YOUR
CLOSENESS CHOI. THAT WILL BE
MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE VIA.
THANK YOU.
NEXT UP MISTER PATTERSON.
WE'LL BE PRESENTING IN.
ON AB TWENTY FIFTY NINE ANOTHER
SUSPENSE CANDIDATE.
BUT MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS WE
SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY PRESENT.
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE. IT
WILL PROVIDE PARENTS WHO HAVE
EXPERIENCED A STILLBIRTH.
WITH A TAX CREDIT OF UP TO TWO
THOUSAND DOLLARS TO ASSIST WITH
THE ASSOCIATED COSTS.
THESE PARENTS THEN HAVE TWO
INDOOR FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS.
AND WITH RESPECT TO MEDICAL
EXPENSES FUNERAL ARRANGEMENTS
GRIEF COUNSELING THINGS OF THAT
NATURE.
AND WHILE THIS BILL.
CANNOT TAKE AWAY FROM THEM THE
LOSS THAT THEY'VE EXPERIENCED.
IT CAN PROVIDE AN INCREDIBLE
RELIEF FOR FAMILIES. UP IN NEED
AND HELP TO REALLY LIFT THE
BURDEN.
AB TWENTY TO FIFTY NINE PASSED
UNANIMOUSLY IN THE ASSEMBLY
REVENUE AND TAXATION COMMITTEE.
AND I RESPECTFULLY. REQUESTING
YOUR SUPPORT DUH WHEN IT ECHOES
TO STE SUSPENSE.
TESTIFIED TO HAVE THE BILL IS
MISTER GAVIN FERGUSON HE AND HIS
WIFE WERE FOUNDERS OF THE
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION PHOEBE'S
FUND. ALSO WITH THIS IS MRS
DURING TO GREGORY WHO IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF A LOCAL VOLUNTEER RUN
SUPPORT GROUP. SHARING PARENTS
OF SACRAMENTO.
I THINK YOU'RE JUST WONDERING MY
THE WITNESSES YOU HAVE TWO
MINUTES EACH AND WE TRY TO KEEP
OUR COMMENTS IN THIS COMMITTEE
TO.
S. CLUBHOUSES.
THANK YOU.
MY DAUGHTER PHOEBE WAS DUE
AUGUST SIXTH TWENTY FIFTEEN AND
ON AUGUST ELEVENTH WHICH WAS
FIVE DAYS AFTER HER DUE DATE.
OUR DOCTOR COULDN'T FIND A
HEARTBEAT ON A ROUTINE
APPOINTMENT.
SHE QUICKLY PULLED HER INTO
ANOTHER ROOM WITH AN ULTRASOUND
AND STARTED TO LOOK AT OUR
DAUGHTER AND AS SOON AS HE HAD
HER ON THE SCREEN.
WE CAN ALL SEE THAT HER LITTLE
HEART WAS NO LONGER BEATING. HE
THEN LOOKED AT US AND SAID THE
WORST WORDS ANYONE COULD EVER
SAY TO A PERSON BUT I'M SORRY
BUT YOUR BABY HAS DIED.
NO THAT THE LEVEL OF GRIEF FELL
FROM PARENTS WHO NEVER GET TO
HOLD THEIR BABY HAVE TO LEAVE
THE HOSPITAL WITH NOTHING IN
THEIR ARMS. LIVE IN A HOUSE WITH
AN EMPTY NURSERY THAT THEY BUILT
IS A PAIN THAT NO ONE IS
EQUIPPED TO HANDLE. AND OFTEN
SWELL OF COUPLES HOLE. THIS IS
WHY AB TWO TWO FIVE NINE IS SO
IMPORTANT.
IT'S NOT BAD ENOUGH THE PARENTS
HAVE TO SURF THE WAVES OF GRIEF
FOR THE REST OF THEIR LIVES
MORNING A CHILD THAT THEY NEVER
GET TO WATCH GROW UP.
BUT THEY ALSO HAVE TO DEAL WITH
UNEXPECTED EXPENSES THAT ADD
INSULT TO INJURY FUNERAL COSTS.
BURIAL OR CREMATION COSTS
WORKING AFTER SOMETHING LIKE
THIS IS IMPOSSIBLE.
SO THERE'S LACK OF INCOME IN
SOME CASES IN SOME COUPLES NEED
TO LEAVE THEIR HOUSE OR TOWN FOR
A BIT TO COLLECT THEIR THOUGHTS
AND BE ALONE.
FINALLY THE MOST ROBUST AS
MEDICAL EXPENSES TO PAY FOR THE
BIRTH OF THE BABY THAT YOU NOW
HAVE TO BURY.
MY WIFE AND I CREATED A CHARITY
CALLED PHOEBE'S FIND THAT GIVES
GRANTS TO COUPLES THAT THEY CAN
GET THERE BECAUSE.
WHICH IS ANOTHER EXPRESSED
EXPENSE THE MOST DON'T CONSIDER.
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN OUR DAUGHTER
PHOEBE ELAINE FERGUSON WAS ONE
OF TWENTY SIX THOUSAND STILL
PERSON AMERICA AND IT'S FAR MORE
COMMON THAN PEOPLE REALIZE THE
PARENTS OF THOSE TWENTY SIX
THOUSAND. BORN STILL EVERY YEAR
NEED HELP.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO PLEASE
APPROVED AB TWO TWO FIVE NINE.
AND DO WHAT YOU CAN FOR PEOPLE
LIKE ME AND MY WIFE AND EFFORT
LIKE THIS GOES MUCH MUCH FURTHER
THAN YOU THINK. AND CAN BE
SOMETHING THAT HELPS AND THE
TIME WHEN PEOPLE LIKE US FEEL
HELPLESS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS TERRIFIC
GREGORY AND I AM A MOTHER OF
THREE CHILDREN.
TO AND HAVE BEEN AND ONE WITH ME
I'M ALSO VOLUNTEER ASSURING
PARENTS A NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
IN SACRAMENTO THAT PROVIDES
EMOTIONAL SUPPORT TO FAMILIES
THAT HAVE EXPERIENCED THE DEATH
OF THEIR BABIES. I'M HERE TO
SHOW MY SUPPORT FOR AB TWO TWO
FIVE NINE. ON NOVEMBER TWENTY
FOURTH TWO THOUSAND EIGHT I
RECEIVED A PHONE CALL THAT WOULD
CHANGE MY LIFE FOREVER. AT THAT
TIME I WAS TWENTY TWO WEEKS
PREGNANT CARRYING MY SECOND
CHILD A GIRL. MY OBGYN CALLED ME
AFTER REVIEWING MY OLD ROUTINE
ULTRASOUND IMAGES IT APPEARED
THAT MY DAUGHTER HAD TO HER
CHAMBERS INSTEAD OF FOUR SHED
SEVERE SWELLING IN HER BRAIN A
CLEFT PALATE AND POSSIBLY OTHER
CHROMOSOMAL ABNORMALITIES.
SHE FURTHER EXPLAINS THAT THE
COMBINATION OF THESE ISSUES WERE
LEGAL MEANING THAT MY BABY WOULD
EITHER DIE IN UTERO HER BE
STILLBORN. I THINK I STOPPED
BREATHING IN THAT MOMENT
CHERISH KATHERINE DIED ON
DECEMBER THIRD TWO THOUSAND ANY.
I LEFT THE HOSPITAL WITH MY
DAUGHTER'S FOOTPRINT AND LIEU OF
HER IN MY ARMS.
INSTEAD OF SPENDING MY NEXT FEW
DAYS GETTING SETTLED IN AT HOME
WITH A NEW BABY I WENT TO A
FUNERAL HOME TO MAKE
ARRANGEMENTS TO HONOR CHURCHES
LIFELESS BODY. AS IF THE
EMOTIONAL TOLL ISN'T ENOUGH
THERE WERE CONSIDERABLE
FINANCIAL HARDSHIPS I HAD TO
ENTER. I OF THE HOSPITAL FOR MY
STAY I WOULD THE FUNERAL HOME
FOR THE TRANSFER OF CHURCHES
BODY FROM THE HOSPITAL WHICH HAD
TO BE APPROVED AND GRANTED BY
THE HOSPITAL. AND FOR CREMATION
EXPENSES I OF THE HOSPITAL FOR
THE SURGERY I HAD TO HAVE JUST
TWO WEEKS AFTER CHURCH WAS BORN
BECAUSE SOMEHOW PART OF THE
PLACENTA HAD REMAINED ATTACHED
TO MY ROOM. CAUSING FURTHER
MEDICAL COMPLICATIONS FOR ME. I
WOULD FOR ALL THE COUNSELING
THAT FOLLOWED MY SUFFERING.
THROUGH ALL OF MY GRIEF ONE OF
THE WORST EXPERIENCES WITH
MORNING FOR MY ACCOUNTANT BUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHICH
FORCED ME TO DENY THAT SHARES
EVER EXISTED. I HAD TO FACE THE
STOCKS AGAIN AFTER HE SUFFERED A
MISCARRIAGE IN MY THIRD
PREGNANCY.
TO ME THIS SIMPLY DEFIED LOGIC I
KNOW MANY FAMILIES TO MY
VOLUNTEER WORK THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE FINANCIAL
RELIEF THAT THIS BILL WILL
PROVIDE. THEM ALL THIS BILL
CANNOT TAKE AWAY FROM THE
PARENTS LOSS OF A CHILD IT WILL
ENSURE THAT FAMILIES AREN'T
BURDEN FINANCIALLY. FOR A BABY
THEY WERE NEVER ABLE TO BRING
HOME. I SINCERELY THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO MY STORY TODAY AND
CONSIDERING THIS MONUMENTALLY
IMPORTANT BILL.
THANK YOU DOWN ARE THERE
ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS RIGHT.
IT'S YOUR NAME THE ORGANIZATION
IN YOUR POSITION.
MY NAME IS STACY FERGUSON I.
ALONG WITH MY HUSBAND WE
STARTED PHOEBE'S FUND A CHARITY.
MY SECOND CHILD WAS BORN SIX
DAYS AFTER HER DUE DATE MANY
MANY PEOPLE HAVE ASKED WHAT THEY
CAN DO TO HELP PEOPLE LIKE ME
AND THE ANSWER IS.
TO PASS THIS BILL ALTHOUGH IT
DOESN'T BRING OUR BABIES BACK IT
DOES.
GIVE FAMILIES OF LOST SOME
RELIEF IN THE DIGNITY DO THEY
DESERVE.
IT'S NOT SPECIAL TREATMENT BUT
EQUAL TREATMENTPARENTS OF
LIVING CHILDREN AND ALSO I
SUPPORT IT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER SUPPORTERS.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE FILE.
WIDGET I SEEN A QUESTIONS WHICH
I TO GET UP CLOSE VERY QUICKLY I
KNOW THE UP THAT THE MISSION OF
THE.
CHAIR WITH RESPECT TO THE
FINANCIAL. ANALYSIS ETCETERA.
.
WE UNDERSTAND IT SOMEWHERE
AROUND A MILLION OR MILLION HALF
DOLLARS ANNUALLY WITH RESPECT TO
THE PRICE TAG.
I'M.
I ONLY ASK THAT WE.
BALANCE WHAT IS A VERY SMALL.
COST TO THE STATE WITH A.
HUGE.
WEIGHT LIFTING OPPORTUNITY HERE.
FOR OUT FAMILIES WHO HAVE GONE
THROUGH THESE DIFFICULT.
AND SO I ASK NOT WITHSTANDING
ITS.
RELATIVELY SMALL COST.
THAT YOU CONSIDERED FAVORABLY.
.
WHEN YOU VOTE ASSISTANCE BY.
REQUEST THAT
RESPECTFULLY FOR YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
I AT THIS TIME I TAKE A MOTION
FOR MR BLOOM'S AB TWENTY FIVE
TWENTY EIGHT SO MOVED.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
A SECOND BY MISS FRIEDMAN LIKE
IT'S OUT ON OF THE ROLL CALL.
NEXT IT LOOKS LIKE A.
MISTER BERMAN.
MISTER BERMAN YOU WILL BE
PRESENTING ON AB TWENTY FORTY
FIVE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY TWO FORTY FIVE A
CLARIFY THAT THE VOTER PRE
REGISTRATION DATA OF MINERS WHO
WILL NOT BE EIGHTEEN BY THE TIME
OF THE NEXT ELECTION BE KEPT
CONFIDENTIAL AND PROHIBITED FROM
DISCLOSURE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ARE THERE SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO FILE.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS THAT'S A
MOTION BY MISTER BIGELOW SECOND
BY A MISS KOREA WHICH OCT CLOSE.
RESPECT THAT FOREVER AND IT HAD
ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU MISTER
GLORIA.
YOU'LL BE PRISON AB THIRTY ONE
THIRTY ONE ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING THE PRESENT AB THIRTY
ONE THIRTY ONE MOVES AVAILABLE.
FOR THE MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK
IN A SECOND BY MYSTERIOUS.
IN SOME NOW CHAIR THIS WAS.
EXECUTIVE ORDER PASSED BY
PRESIDENT OBAMA RESCINDED BY
PRESIDENT TRUMP WE WOULD LIKE TO
STILL IT AYE IN LAW HERE IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I DO YOU HAVE A
WITNESS.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING RONALD
COLMAN HERE.
GOOD MORNING WELCOME HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU OF CALIFORNIA
ALSO HEAR THE SPONSORED IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE THAT BRINGS
ACCOUNTABILITY TO HOW.
ACQUISITION MILITARY EQUIPMENT
HAPPENS AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND
WE ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU JUST SAW SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
ABOUT JIM WONDERED ON BEHALF OF
THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA
COSPONSORED AND SUPPORT ALSO
SPEAKING TODAY ON BEHALF OF THE.
CALVET COUNSEL FOR AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS IN SUPPORT.
AND.
INDIVISIBLE THANK YOU.
AND EVERYTHING THAT ASIAN
MARKETS ABOUTUS CALIFORNIA
CHUNKS PART.
OTHERS SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS WHO SHALL
MUCH LARA BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION
OPPOSITION DUE TO THE COST TO
TAXPAYERS AND LOCAL GOVERNMENT
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE FILE.
SEEN NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU AYE
VOTE THANK ECONOMY ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER GLORIA THE
CONVENTION.
MISTER CALDERON WHICH AT
PRESENT.
YOU'LL BE PRESENTING FIRST ON
YOUR OWN A. B. EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS A
BEATEN NO FOR SECOND STRASBOURG
REQUEST.
EXPECT WESTERN AYE VOTE.
SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING KELLY MIGHT BE WITH
THE ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST ME SIEU IN
SUPPORT OF AB EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
FOR AS ALL BE AN IMPORTANT
MEASURE. OUGHT TO HELP EDUCATE
CALIFORNIANS ABOUT THE ISSUE OF
PLASTIC POLLUTION AND EMPOWER
THEM TO MAKE SIMPLE DECISIONS. I
DON'T HAVE AN ASKED TO RELIEVE
THE SUPPORT OF NATIONAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL STOP
WASTE HILL THE BAY. AND
SURFRIDER FONDATION THINKING.
THE BIGGER WITH THEIR AND
REDUCES HITS THE MONTEREY BAY
AQUARIUM IN SUPPORT.
ENVIRONMENT CALIFORNIA DAN
JACOBSON STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
SO OBVIOUSLY SHALL BE HAVE THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO
IN SUPPORT.
JOHN THE CLEAR ABOUT THE
STUDENTS IN NEED OF SOME
SUPPORT.
BECAUSE IN OPPOSITION.
SEE NOW DEPARTMENT FINANCE THE
FINAL.
I SEE NO QUESTIONS ARE JUDGE
CLOSE. BUT WESTERN ABOUT THAT
GETS OUT ON A B. ROLL CALL THANK
YOU MISTER CALDERON MIKE
UNDERSTAND YOU'RE ALSO
PRESENTING FOR MISTER DAILY AB
TWENTY SEVEN SEVENTY SEVEN IT
ENJOYS DO PASSES MENDED EXTEND
THE SUNSET BY THREE TWO THREE
YEARS. AGO.
SHARE EARLIER MOTION BY MISTER
BELLONA SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK.
AUTHOR ACCEPTS THE AMENDMENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK ABOUT.
SPEAKERS AND SPORT.
BEAKERS IN OPPOSITE OF KEVIN CAN
WITH INTERNET ASSOCIATION.
I'M.
THIS BILL IS IMPORTANT TO.
CONTINUE ALLOWED STEAM PLACE TO
HAVE THESE TRAVEL OPTIONS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I CONTINUE
UNTIL OFTEN PLAYS TEE SHIRTS
FROM MICHAEL'S AND
TRANSPORTATION NETWORK
COMPANIES.
COULD RESULT IN COST AVOIDANCE
FOR DEPARTMENTS.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WHICH I TO
CLOSE REQUEST WHEN I HOPE I GET
OUT ON A ROLL CALL THANK YOU.
IT'S FRIEDMAN WHICH I PLAN.
YEAH A COUPLE BILLS IT WILL
START WITH AB TWENTY TWO SIXTY
THREE IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY TWO SUSAN VALERIA
ALLOWS FOR THE ADOPTED FOR USE
OF HISTORIC BUILDINGS BY
RELAXING LOCAL PARKING CODES.
LEAVE THE MOTION BY MISCREANTS
SECOND BY A MISTER QUIRK FURTHER
SPEAKERS OF SKIN SUPPORT.
ANY SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WHICH I CLOSE.
REQUEST REMOVAL THAT GETS OUT ON
A B. ROLL CALL THE SECOND ONE
THAT YOU HAVE TODAY IT LOOKS
LIKE A B. TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY
TWO.
AND ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WOULD MOTION BY MISTER OBERNOLTE
A SECOND BY MISTER QUIRK.
I RESPECTFULLY.
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE FOR A BILL
THAT WOULD HELP TO.
MAKE SEQUEL LITTLE BIT
FRIENDLIER TO THE BUILDING OF
HOUSING.
THANK YOU ARE SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT.
SPEAKERS IN OPPOSITION.
SEEN NOT DEPARTMENT FINANCE NO
FOR.
CNN AND THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL
CALL WITH MISTER BIGELOW NOT
VOTING IN MISTER FUNG NOT
VOTING.
THANK YOU.
AND I DID SEE YOU SITTING THERE
YOU LOOK LIKE A KID.
THAT'S A COMPLIMENT WHEN.
YOU'RE MIDDLE AGED WOMAN.
AB TWENTY SIX OH FIVE.
THAT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
SECOND. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
MYSTERIOUS A SECOND BY MISTER
QUIRK.
PROJECT PROCEED.
YES JUST LIKE TO THANK THIS
COMMITTEE.
REPAIRMAN STRICTLY ASKING AYE
VOTE ON A ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SIX OH FIVE.
FOR FOSTER YOU'VE.
I DO HAVE SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT
YES LUCY SAUCEDO CARTER POLICY
ADVOCATE WITH THE YOUTH LAW
CENTER WHERE ONE OF THE CO
SPONSORING ORGANIZATIONS AND ASK
FOR YOUR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ARE THERE ANY SPEAKERS
IN OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
NO FILE.
SEE NO QUESTIONS WOULD YOU LIKE
CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY ASK WHAT I VOTE AND
THAT GETS OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THANK YOU MISTER GIPSON.
SO I'M GONNA PRESENT BUT WE ARE
LOOKING FOR MR LOW MISTER MULLIN
MISTER MURATSUCHI OR MISS RUBIO.
MANY PERCENT ON THE CLAIMS
.
AND CHAIR YOU HAVE THE AB
SEVENTEEN SEVENTY THREE.
SO DO PASSED WE HAVE A MOTION.
I THINK THIS IS THE ANNUAL
CLAIMS BILL INTO. HAS A.
.
AN APPROPRIATION OF OVER ELEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS IN ONE TIME
FUNDING FOR THREE SPECIFIC
SETTLEMENTS THAT ARE ALREADY OUT
BY NEED STATE OBLIGATIONS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THEM ABOUT.
IS THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING SIR AT THE PIT WITH
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY OTHER ADDITIONAL WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
KNOW FILE.
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
SEEING NONE THIS GETS OUT UNABLE
BECAUSE.
WHO'S NEXT.
MISTER MURATSUCHI I SIERRA. IN
THE AUDIENCE.
YOU'RE HERE WITH AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE.
OR A.
I AM HERE TO PRESENT TO AB
TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY NINE. A BILL
THAT WOULD REQUIRE THE STATE
AUDITOR'S. AUDITOR TO OBTAIN
APPROVAL FROM THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE.
PRIOR TO CONDUCTING AN INITIAL
ASSESSMENT AND AUDIT OF A HIGH
RISK LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
THIS BILL PASSED
THE POLICY COMMITTEE ON A FIVE
TO ONE VOTE.
AND THE SPECIAL COMMITTEES
ANALYSIS INDICATES MINOR COST TO
THE STATE AUDITOR.
SO NORMALLY I WOULD JUST STOP
HERE AND SAY I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AYE VOTE. BUT I UNDERSTAND
THAT THERE MAY BE SOME FURTHER
QUESTIONS REGARDING THIS BILL.
I'M JUST A FOR THE RECORD THAT
IS THE CHAIR OF THE JOINT LESS
THAN ABOUT A COMMITTEE. I FULLY
SUPPORT THE HIGH RISK LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AUDIT PROGRAM AND I
FULLY SUPPORT THE STATE AUDITOR
ELAINE HOUSE WORK ON THIS
PROGRAM.
THE PROBLEM HERE IS THAT THE
LESS THAN A COUNCIL.
ISSUED A WRITTEN LEGAL OPINION
THAT UNDER EXISTING LAW THE
STATE AUDITOR DOES NOT HAVE THE
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT AN IN
SO ASSESSMENT. OF A HIGH RISK
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCY BEYOND A
VERY LIMITED SCOPE.
THIS BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS THAT
PROBLEM BY REQUIRING JAIL LACK
TO PROVE THE INITIAL ASSESSMENT.
AND AUDIT PRIOR TO MOVING
FORWARD YOU THE MOTION BY MISTER
CALDERON IN A SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE.
IDEA. HAPPEN ANSWERING
QUESTIONS
PERFECT TO HAVE SPEAKERS AND
SUPPORT I DO NOT SPEAKERS IN
OPPOSITION.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NO FILE.
WE DISCUSS I DON'T HAVE A
RECOMMENDATION ON THIS I'M GONNA
BE STAYING OFF I'M STILL. I I I
DON'T KNOW I FULLY UNDERSTANDS
THE ISSUE WELL ENOUGH TO VOTE ON
IT TODAY BUT I'M NOT CONCERNED
ABOUT THE FINANCIAL.
RAMIFICATIONS OF THE BILL SO
THANK YOU FOR COMING PRESENTED
TO MISTER PARK HAS A QUESTION
BOMB YA. I'LL BE STAYING OFF AS
WELL MY CONCERN IS I WOULD JUST
LIKE TO GIVE THEM THE AUTHORITY
PERIOD. AND IT WOULD SAVE MONEY
IF THE.
.
COMMITTEE DOESN'T HAVE TO.
OKAY ACT AND THEREFORE I'M
GOING TO BE STAYING OFF BECAUSE
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD SPEND
EVEN THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY. OKAY
WELL LET LET ME JUST TO LAY OUT
THE BASIC ISSUE IS WHETHER THERE
SHOULD BE ANY CHECKS AND
BALANCES BETWEEN THE LEGISLATURE
OF THE STATE AUDITOR.
.
THE THE ISSUE IS WHETHER THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD EXERCISE
OVERSIGHT.
THROUGH J. LIKE RECEIVING
NOTIFICATION OF ANY POTENTIAL
HIGH RISK AUDIT IN YOUR
COMMUNITY UP PRIOR TO THE
AUDITOR GOING ON YOU AND YOUR
COMMITTEE TO CONDUCT
INVESTIGATIONS AND SO. PURCHASE
IT RATHER THAN JUST HAVING THE
JAIL LIKE APPROVAL AT THE AUDIT
STAGE WE'RE JUST TRYING TO MOVE
UP. THE POINT AT WHICH J. LACK.
.
REQUIRES THE OUGHT TO COME
BEFORE THE LEGISLATURE THROUGH
THE JAIL LACK TO.
A TO INDICATE WHAT THEY PLAN TO
DO YEAH I JUST DON'T THINK
POLITICIANS SHOULD BE INVOLVED.
I DON'T TRUST HIM.
I THINK.
I THINK YOU'RE ADVOCATING THE
LEGISLATORS OVERSIGHT
RESPONSIBILITY.
I'M GONNA M. THERE'S NO
CONFUSION ON THE VOTES BUT.
.
WE HAVE A MOTION A SECOND AND.
SO YOU HAVE QUESTION I'M SORRY
MISTER OBERNOLTE IT AND SEE.
I THINK YOU MANAGER OF MISTER
MARCHI ENORMOUS. A SUPPORTER OF
WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE
DEFINITELY THINK THAT THE.
DEGREE OF OVERSIGHT THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS OVER.
THE AUDITOR SHE IN THOSE HIGH
RISK AUDIT SITUATION SHOULD BE
CLARIFIED BECAUSE IT'S VERY
UNCLEAR RIGHT NOW.
.
SO I APPRECIATE YOU ARE TAKING
ON THE ISSUE I UNDERSTAND
SENATOR LARA HAS A BILL ON THIS
EXACT SAME TOPIC IN THE AUDITOR
ALSO HAS CONCERNS ARE YOU
CONFIDENT THAT THE THREE OF YOU
ARE GOING TO GET TO A PLACE
THAT.
EVERYONE AGREES AND AND.
WE CAN HAVE ONE UNIFIED FRONT
MOVING FORWARD ON THIS YES.
THE STATE AUDITOR AND CENTER
LARA AND I HAD MASSED.
IT'S AND SARAH LAUREN. AGREED
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS
TOGETHER.
SEVERAL LARA RECOGNIZES THAT.
THERE IS A LEGAL PROBLEM HERE
THAT NEEDS TO BE FIXED.
THE ONLY DIFFERENCE BETWEEN MY
BILL ON SEVERAL LARA SPILL. IS
THAT I'M ASKING FOR THE J. LIKE
APPROVAL TO BE.
MOVED UP EARLIER IN THE PROCESS.
HIS IS YOU KNOW FOR JAIL ACT TO
UP TO PROVE THE AUDIT.
BUT.
ITS ACT WHETHER IT'S A SARAH
LAWRENCE VERSION OR MY VERSION
THERE IS STILL A CHECK IF THE
ONLY QUESTION IS AT WHAT POINT
DOES JAIL LIKE CHECKING.
BUT I AM CONFIDENT THAT WE WILL
WORK IT OUT THIS IS ORIGINALLY
CENTER LAURA'S.
BABY THIS IS GONNA HE IS THE
ORIGINAL AUTHOR OF THE HIGH RISK
LOCAL AUDIT. PROGRAM. AND IF HE
ADDRESSES THE ISSUES THAT I'M
RAISING I'D BE PERFECTLY HAPPY
TO DROP MY BILL.
BUT AS THEIR INSTITUTIONAL
MATTER I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE.
AN OPPORTUNITY TO CHECK AND.
YOU KNOW WITHOUT THE STATE
AUDITOR.
THAT BEING OF THE GO OUT
CONDUCT INVESTIGATIONS WITHOUT
ANY LESS THAN.
APPROVED ART BUT THINK IT'S GOOD
TO HEAR THAT I'M HAPPY TO
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU MA'AM MISTER
MURATSUCHI.
I'M I'M HOPEFUL THEY AND.
AS ISSUES FOR YOU WILL.
WORK WITH MRS CENTER LARA
OBVIOUSLY I HAVE BEEN THIS BILL
WILL. GO TO HIS COMMITTEE AND
NICE I ONLY UNDERSTAND THAT
OKAY.
WITH THAT THIS GETS OUT ON ME
B. ROLL CALL WITH MISTER
OBERNOLTE I'M SORRY DOESN'T
QUITE GET OUT YET
I'M SORRY IF YOU CAN FIND MISTER
GARCIA THEN YOUR BILL WILL GET
OUT TELL SOMETHING.
IMAGE IT'S ON CALL FOR RIGHT
NOW CONCERT WASN'T COUNTY
CORRECTLY MYSTERY GARCIA MYSTERY
GARCIA WOOD LOOKING FOR THEIR
HUNTING DOWN. ALRIGHT I WILL
HUNT THEM DOWN THANK YOU.
I MISTER MULLIN.
MR MALLIA BE PRESENTING ON AB
TWENTY FIVE FORTY IT ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
THANK YOU AND I MISTER CALDERON
WHERE MEMBERS ARE MYSTERIOUS.
AB TWENTY FIVE FORTY SIX TO
ENSURE THE PUBLIC FACILITIES ARE
MADE AVAILABLE FOR USE AS VOTE
CENTERS THIS IS ESPECIALLY
IMPORTANT AS AS BEFORE FIFTY THE
CALIFORNIA VOTERS CHOICE ACT.
RULES OUT ACROSS THE STATE
STARTING WITH COUNTIES LIKE
MINDS HIM TALE WHILE FEWER
LOCATIONS ARE NEEDED ON ELECTION
DAY ITSELF A NUMBER OF LOCATION
THE DURING DURING THE EARLY
VOTING PERIOD IS SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASED UNDER. SP FOUR FIFTY
SO PUBLIC FACILITY SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES AND OTHERS ARE QUICK
WITH WIFI. OTHER ACCESSIBLE
CITIES RIGHT IDEAL LOCATIONS
THIS BILL WILL SIMPLY PROVIDE
THAT ELECTION ELECTIONS
ADMINISTRATOR SOMEHOW MORE
RESEARCH WITH WITH MORE
RESOURCES AND ULTIMATELY MAKE
CERTAIN THAT VOTERS HAVE ACCESS
TO VOTE CENTERS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. I HAVE WITH ME RYAN
RONCO.
WHO IS THE PLASTER COUNTY CHIEF
CLERK
HOW TO OFFER ADDITIONAL COMMENTS
AND SUPPORT AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE?
THANK YOU SPEAKERS IN SUPPORT.
YEAH GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
RIGHT OKAY WILL PROSECUTE A
COURT REPORTER REGISTRAR VOTERS
AND DIE HERE AS CO CHAIR OF THE
SICK CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
PARKS IN ELECTIONS OFFICIALS.
LEGISLATION COMMITTEE CO CHAIR
RIGHT HERE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU ADDITIONAL SUPPORTERS.
JONATHAN CLAY ABOUT THE COUNTY
SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT.
ARE THERE ANY PEOPLE IN
OPPOSITION.
SEEN NONE NOT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE.
THE FILE.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
S. FOREVER THINK IT'S OUT ON IN
IRAQ CALL THANK YOU MISTER MIND
MR LOW.
YOU HAVE A BE TWENTY EIGHT
SEVENTY THREE TO ENJOYS A DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION.
WELL THE BILL.
BY MISS CARILLO SECOND BY A.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
MANY VERY MUCH VENTURE MEMBERS
THIS BILL CLOSE THE LOOPHOLE.
AYE BY PROHIBITING A PERSONAL
VEHICLE ASSURING PROGRAM FROM
FACILITATING A MANUFACTURED
RECALL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOREVER.
AT ANY SPEAKERS AT SUPPORT
BRIEFLY.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
I'M ROSEMARY SHE HIM PRESIDENT
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO RELIABILITY
AND SAFETY.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS
AND THE AND THE SPONSORS EFFORTS
TO. ADDRESS SAFETY RECALLS IN A
RESPONSIBLE WAY THAT FITS THEIR
BUSINESS MODEL.
WITHOUT WAITING FOR A TRAGEDY
TO OCCUR AND I'VE ALSO BEEN
ASKED TO EXPRESS SUPPORT FROM
COPPER CONSUMER ACTION THIS
SAFETY INSTITUTE THE TRAUMA
FOUNDATION. BUT CENTER FOR AUTO
SAFETY. AND CONSUMER WATCHDOG
AND ALEXANDER BRAVE MEN WHOSE
DAUGHTER JEWEL WAS KILLED BY AN
UNREPAIRED RECALLED RENTAL CAR.
WE'VE RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIFLE.
THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ARE ANYMORE
REPRESENTING TRURO WHICH IS ONE
OF THE PERSONAL VEHICLE SHARING
COMPANIES TO WHICH THIS.
PROPOSAL WOULD APPLY.
WE SUPPORT THE BILL AND WE JUST
NOTE THAT THE MODEL CONTINUES TO
OPERATE REGARDLESS OF WHETHER OR
NOT THIS PASSES TO IMPROVE THE
SAFETY THINKING.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. SILVIO
HURRYING TO HAVE TO GET AROUND
IN SUPPORT.
FIGURES IN OPPOSITION.
VERY BROAD IN BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS THIS SYSTEM.
ARE A BILL IN WOLF'S CLOTHING
IT'S A BILL SPONSORED BY TORO TO
TRY TO.
GET THEM INTO A PLACE WHERE
THEY'RE NOT A RENTAL CAR COMPANY
BECAUSE RENTAL CAR COMPANIES ARE
COVERED BY THESE RULES.
AND THE WHOLE POINT IS THAT THEY
DON'T HAVE TO BEHAVE LIKE A
RENTAL CAR COMPANY WHICH
INVOLVES ALL SORTS OF CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
AND REVENUE FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND THE BUSINESS
MODEL IS JUST ANOTHER ONE OF
THESE THINGS WHERE IT'S A RENTAL
CAR COMPANY WITH THE NAP.
AND THEREFORE THEY SHOULDN'T BE
TREATED TO THE SAME RULES AND
SHOULD GET ABA. A I'D ED JOHN
COMPETITION.
.
IT AN UNFAIR PLAYING FIELD SO WE
ARE GENOVA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU
S. OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
MITCH SNIDER WITH CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION ECHO THE
COMMENTS OF THE TEAMSTERS ALSO
UPSET.
THANK YOU DEPARTMENT FINANCE.
THE FILE.
I'M GONNA M..
I HAVE RECOMMENDED AND TO PASS
THIS OUT ON FINANCES I AM NOT
COMFORTABLE WITH THE POLICY NOT
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY.
WE WANT EVERYBODY TO NOT USE
RECALLS.
VEHICLES IT SEEMS OBVIOUS I
THINK I THE COMPANIES IN GOOD
FAITH COULD AND SHOULD DO THIS
WITHOUT THIS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. I'M A LITTLE
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE PUTTING ON
THE THUMB ON THE SCALE OF
DETERMINING.
WHETHER OR NOT THESE ARE NOT
RENTAL CAR AGENCIES IN OUR
PACKED A DIFFERENT FORM AND
THAT'S A DIFFERENT QUESTION I
UNDERSTAND. FOR A DIFFERENT BILL
I WAS TOLD PROBABLY NEXT YEAR OR
IN THE FUTURE I'M ONE WHICH I
OBVIOUSLY. HAVE PERSONAL
FEELINGS BOUT IN A NOT
SUPPORTIVE OF.
BUT GIVEN THE SCOPE OF THIS
BILL AND WHAT IT DOES IN FOR
SAFETY WE RECOMMEND AN AYE VOTE.
ON.
THE FINANCES I WILL NOT BE
VOTING ON THIS BILL TODAY.
BUT I LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATION.
KIND OF.
SPLITTING THE BABY A LOT I NOW
THAT.
THANK YOU FOR THE WHICH I CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SAY AGAIN THIS BILL IS
SIMPLY REQUIRES A THAT IN THIS A
TECHNOLOGY COMPANY TO THE
SUBJECT OF THIS SEEMS.
CONSUMER PROTECTION STANDARDS
THAT WE HAVE AND SO WITH THAT
RESPECT THAT ASPECT OF IT.
THANK YOU LIKE IT'S OUT ON A
ROLL CALL WITH MISS FRIEDMAN
VOTING NOW IN THE CHAIR VOTING
NOW. THANK YOU.
A WELCOME YOU'RE DONE YOU'RE
OUT.
GO. AWAY.
JUST A GAME UP SO I TEND TO
MISTER MERCI CHEESE TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY NINE THAT GETS OUT ON A
B. ROLL CALL WITH MR OBERNOLTE
VOTING AYE THE CHAIR AND MISS
FRIEDMAN AND MISTER QUIRK NOT
VOTING.
ALRIGHT.
WITH THAT IF WE CAN GET A
MOTION ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
I MOTION BY MISTER QUIRK A
SECOND BY MISTER OBERNOLTE CAN
YOU MAN CHECKING PLEASE RATE
READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY NINE. NINETEEN
FORTY THREE NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE. TWENTY
EIGHTY SEVEN TWENTY ONE FORTY
FIVE TWENTY ONE FIFTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO FIFTY FIVE. TWENTY
THREE FORTY SIX TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY THREE TWENTY THREE EIGHTY
EIGHT TWENTY FOUR FIFTY ONE
TWENTY FIVE TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY TWO TWENTY SIX SIXTY
SEVEN TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY NINE OH FOUR. THREE NINE
FOURTEEN TWENTY NINE SIXTY SEVEN
THIRTY NINETY EIGHT.
THIRTY FORTY ONE AND.
THIRTY ONE FORTY NINE AND THIRTY
TO FIFTY SIX.
AND THAT CONSENT COUNTER GETS
OUT ON A ROLL CALL AT THIS TIME
WILL READ.
THE BILL'S IT'LL BE MOVING TO
THE SUSPENSE FILE.
AND.
JERRY.
SEVENTEEN THIRTY FOUR SEVENTEEN
SIXTY FIVE. NINETEEN FIFTY SIX
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN NINETEEN
NINETY TWENTY FIFTY TWENTY SIXTY
SIX TWENTY ONE ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY ONE EIGHTY
THREE. TWENTY ONE EIGHTY EIGHT
TWENTY TWO ELEVEN TWENTY TWO
SEVENTEEN TWENTY TO THIRTY FIVE
TWENTY TWO FIFTY NINE TWENTY TWO
NINETY TWO TWENTY THREE TWELVE
TWENTY THREE TWENTY SIX TWENTY
THREE THIRTY ONE TWENTY FOUR
THIRTY.
TWENTY FOUR FIFTY NINE TWENTY
FOUR. SEVENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY FIVE TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY
FOUR TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY NINE
TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX TWENTY SIX
THIRTY SEVEN. TWENTY SIX EIGHTY
TO TWENTY SEVEN HUNDRED TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTEEN TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY SEVEN. TWENTY SEVEN SIXTY
ONE TWENTY NINE TWENTY THREE
TWENTY NINE THIRTY TO. NINE
THIRTY SIX TWENTY NINE FORTY
FIVE TWENTY NINE SIXTY FIVE
THIRTY FIFTEEN THIRTY TWENTY
NINE THIRTY THIRTY THREE. TO
THIRTY SEVEN THIRTY THEIR NINE
THIRTY SEVEN TO THIRTY EIGHTY
SEVEN THIRTY ONE TWENTY. THIRTY
ONE FORTY SEVEN THIRTY ONE FORTY
EIGHT THIRTY ONE SEVENTY SIX AND
THIRTY ONE NINETY SEVEN.
THEY GIVE THOSE HAVE BILLS WILL
BE MOVED TO THE SUSPENSE WHILE
BRINGING THE TOTAL NUMBER OF
BILLS AND SUSPENSE HALL AT
AROUND FIVE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
SIX I WON I THINK EVERY AUTHOR
WHO HAS NOT PRESENTED ON ONE OF
THOSE BILLS.
AND.
WE'D BE HERE LONGTIME IF
EVERYBODY CHOSE TO. WITHOUT MISS
EGGMAN IS GONNA PRESENT ON THE
LAST BILL WE HAVE TODAY FOR MISS
RUBIO AND THAT IS AB TWENTY SIX
NINETY EIGHT IT ENJOYS A DO PASS
RECOMMENDATION.
WE HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER.
BIGELOW SECOND BY MISTER
OBERNOLTE WHICH I PROCEED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH JUST
PRESENTING ON THIS WOMAN BECAUSE
PRIORITY BILL THAT ENABLES
CHILDREN THIS CALIFORNIA STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO BENEFIT
FROM EARLY CHILDHOOD MENTAL
HEALTH AND I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
SPEAKERS AND SUPPORT THAT MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BRING INTO IT ON
BEHALF OF CAN DANGLE AT
NONPROFIT. AND I EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION PROVIDER IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA THE SPONSOR
AND ALSO OF COURSE IN SUPPORT.
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT GOOD MORNING
PAMELA GIVES REPRESENTING THE
LOS ANGELES COUNTY OFFICE OF
EDUCATION WE BELIEVE THE
SERVICES WOULD PROVIDE A GREAT
ASSISTANCE TO CHILDREN BY
KEEPING THEM IN SCHOOL. AND
RESULTING IN SAVINGS WE THINK
THE COST OF THE BILL HAS A DE
MINIMIS SO WE ARE JUST SUPPORT
FOR THE BILL THINK. THANK YOU IS
THERE ANY OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE I AM
DEPARTMENT FINANCING STILL LEFT
US I GUESS THAT MEANS THERE'S NO
FILE. A.
JUST CAN TAKE OUT OF THE NO FLY
I'LL AS SEEN NO DISCUSSION WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
I THINK IT'S OUT ON A ROLL CALL
THINKING A SEGMENT WITH THAT
THAT CONCLUDES  I DO WANT TO
PEOPLE THE AUDIENCE I'M SORRY IF
YOU THERE YOU'RE HERE TO SPEAK
ON I'M ON A BILL THAT WAS MOVED
TO THE SUSPENSE ON FILE. IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION YOU MAY
COME FORWARD.
TELLS THE BILL AND TELL US YOUR
POSITION NOW.
SEEING NONE I. OWE NOW THAT
LAND.
THAT MOVE FAST THIS COMMITTEE
ARE WE JUST MOVE ON. S. AURIEMMA
SPOILER A SEWING DEL FOUNTAIN
WITH ENACT UNIVERSAL HEALTHCARE
FOR CALIFORNIA I HEAR JUST DIE
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTY EIGHTY
SEVEN AND I KNOW YOU DON'T HAVE
A TODAY OF AB TWENTY FIVE STE.
SEVENTEEN HUNDRED EIGHT THOUSAND
SINGLE PAYER SUPPORTERS WERE IN
FULL SUPPORT OF BOTH THOSE
BILLS.
THANK YOU.
SEEN NOBODY ELSE WANTS TO
TESTIFY AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE OUT THIS ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
ADJOURNED TO